three-day weekend over chris has to make
the transition
back to work so what did we talk about
while chris was
in his hammock with uh legs that were
tan and face that was not
um okay one of the things that popped up
last week jerry jones infatuated
reportedly with kyle pitts
my theory is that we know about that
because there are members of the cowboys
organization that don't want kyle pitts
so
they're trying to make sure he's gone
before the cowboys
would take him instead of a defensive
player where they have a much greater
area of need
chris i know kyle pitts is a hell of a
prospect but when you've got
amari cooper and cd lamb and michael
gallup and you've got all the money paid
to dak prescott
the the idea of taking pits if he falls
to you at 10 which he likely won't or
trading up giving up
assets to go get kyle pitts it seems
like a reach but it definitely seems
like something that jerry jones would be
capable of doing
yeah i mean or at least wanting to do
well i mean the dallas is one of those
teams of course that's always
you know sitting there and a little bit
like the raiders bigger faster stronger
they're all about that
you know that guy kyle bits is special
there's no doubt about that but to me
like doesn't make sense does does not
make sense for their football team
to do that you know their offense is in
a good spot
they are and they're not like you know
totally void
at the the tight end position no i know
they don't have kyle pitts but like
dalton schultz is a good football player
you know that to me the the biggest need
with their football team like you said
it's defense defense defense it's across
the board they got they got
issues there and if they're obsessed
with like high-end talent and things
like that like to me
when i look there with dallas right and
you go okay
pass rusher they could do that you know
would that would they do that i don't
know the other one i look
at like corner that certainly seems like
it could be something there would they
take a chance on the caleb farley with
the back surgery type thing
he's that type of talent would they do
it or are they going to go patrick
certain and go the safer route
the guy who's at you know alabama
schooled and all that they got options
but i don't think they need to go to the
offensive side of the ball that's for
sure
oh and how's jerry gonna feel about
players who opted out it's
it's a theme that that definitely is
going to
affect some owners and how they view
players not just from the standpoint of
do you love football but just are you
pushing back against
the status quo can you be trusted to
come in and be that robot that so many
teams are looking for and again i don't
think that's the way it should be but we
have to acknowledge the reality that
some teams may look at it
that way it seems like every seven or
eight years jerry has
one of these it's almost like some sort
of a locust right it was
darren mcfadden in 2008 remember how
smitten he was with getting derrick
mcfadden
so smitten with mcfadden that he drafted
felix jones from arkansas when he
finally had a chance to get on the board
in round one that year was the first guy
from arkansas jones had ever
drafted in 20 years of owning the team
and then it was johnny manziel in 2014
and they basically had to
take the keys to the car away from
pappaw and not let him go get johnny
manziel and that was smart
that was smart then right so uh
this one seems like a much better
prospect than johnny manziel
the question is can you justify that
when your defense has so many areas of
need and your defense has been so
abysmal
especially last year chris yeah that to
me i don't think you can justify it i
don't i just think there's too many
great needs there and you got a
you got a quarterback who's pretty damn
good and special
you know coming back with like you
already mentioned
those receivers you know two good
running backs an offensive line that's
real good that to me just does not make
sense
now i mean there there's a scenario you
could sit there and look at it and go
the bengals you know if they if they
don't take a kyle pitts right after that
you start to look at it and go he could
be on the board there at number 10
pits for the cowboys and what are they
going to do then that's going to be the
big question
you know i don't know they've certainly
been gutsy in the draft before i mean
you mentioned a few
things we could talk about jalen smith
at the top of the second
that was a really risky decision by them
with that knee injury he had
randy gregory you know they've stood you
know strong with him he had issues
coming out in the draft that everybody
knew about so they're not afraid to take
that risky pick
certainly not but uh i just i
i think their their defense was such
crap they need help on that side of the
ball
yeah absolutely i mean their offense is
in really really good shape
and hey maybe they would dangle and
amari cooper to move up a few spots but
uh
nobody's taking amari cooper and paying
him 20 million dollars especially not
with the cap down
so if you look i was gonna say this mike
if you look at like the bengals and they
went penny sewell right
and then you got the dolphins who go
jamar chase
and let's just say the lions do go
quarterback
i i don't think they will but we know
that's a possibility they go just in
fields
and then you know maybe the carolina
panthers
and the broncos go back to offensive
line
or some some other need they have of
their football team
the cowboys could easily be sitting
there at 10 with pits sitting there in
their lap and then what do they do there
will jerry jones take the cheese
i hope not for his sake that he wouldn't
just for the betterment of this football
team
yeah it's it's two sides of the ball and
the defense
was just abysmal last year and i know
they think it's going to instantly be
better with dan quinn but this is the
same group that brought us mike nolan
last year and sold him as the answer and
we saw how badly
that failed hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports